[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver pour un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité dans le département tout de
suite les titres de ce vendredi 15
février
aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale des cancers pédiatriques
ils touchent deux mille cinq cent
cinquante enfants par an reportage à
suivre au sein du service pédiatrique du
centre hospitalier de versailles et le
cancer première cause de décès par
maladie chez l'enfant plus de précision
avec notre invité est jean-pierre le
haut de la ligue contre le cancer des
yvelines
et puis comme chaque vendredi coup
d'oeil sur l'actualité de la semaine
mobilisation des professeurs nuit des
métiers ou encore soul sur l'épilepsie
un mal invisible avec peu de prise en
charge dans le département aujourd'hui
vendredi 15 février journée
internationale du cancer de l'enfant
c'est la première cause de décès par
maladie est le deuxième facteur de
mortalité après les accidents en france
et en europe
immersion au sein du service pédiatrique
du centre hospitalier de versailles 2550
cancers sont diagnostiqués chez les
enfants et adolescents chaque année en
france le docteur sylvie nathan sont
hélas chef du service pédiatrique situé
au 7e étage du centre hospitalier de
versailles tabac c'est une bonne semaine
ouais est ce que tu as des choses
particulières à raconter depuis la
semaine dernière ce que tu as été malade
que les choses n'ont rien de spécial pas
pierre patat pas eu la grippe à l'âge de
4 ans gérault a perdu la vue suit un irm
le diagnostic tombe gérault a une tumeur
cérébrale
un gliome des nerfs optiques tu respires
fort
parfait ok il a eu il avait plusieurs
cycles de chimio sur un an elle même
deux ans la première fois et il a été
opéré
déjà deux fois à necker et il est suivi
toutes les trois mois il a une irm et en
fonction de l'évolution de la tumeur on
décide de reprendre une chimio pas
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu une chimiothérapie
qu'il continuera jusqu'en novembre 2019
à seulement 10 ans le petit garçon est
très lucide sur sa situation
parfois j'ai plusieurs rendez vous par
semaine mais si j'y vais au moins une
fois par semaine
jean marc jacquin commission bio je
respire et je je je pense est quelque
chose que j'aime bien malgré la maladie
géraud à des occupations d'un enfant de
son âge c'est comme les dominos mais il
faut par exemple payer deux couleurs
commune qui les touchent
et ce n'est pas facile le cancer de
jehro une lutte quotidienne depuis
plusieurs années qui a provoqué un
véritable chamboulement pour ses proches
notamment dans la vie professionnelle de
sa mère
c'est un peu le ciel qui nous tombe sur
la tête le quotidien c'est vivre avec un
enfant qui hospitalisée très
régulièrement avec beaucoup de beaucoup
de rendez vous donc voilà je ne
travaille pas je m'occupe de mes enfants
et ça me permet d'être disponible pour
géraud d'aidé qu'il a besoin
le service pédiatrique du centre
hospitalier de versailles prend en
charge une vingtaine d'enfants pour des
cancers six à huit jeunes sont reçus par
jour pour des soins en ambulatoire
ils sont suivis en partenariat avec les
services de cancérologie pédiatrique
parisien alors le premier type de cancer
le plus fréquent ce sont les leucémies
d'enfants
les cancers du sang des anomalies des
cellules sanguines qui prolifèrent donc
ça c'est le premier premier type de
cancer chez l'enfant dans ce service
pédiatrique fresque murale animaux avec
comme but faire oublier la maladie aux
enfants car les cancers pédiatriques se
développent plus rapidement que chez les
adultes
le combat continue pour les médecins
famille et enfant et chaque année en
france plus de 2550 cancers sont
diagnostiqués chez les enfants et
adolescents selon les derniers chiffres
de l'institut national du cancer parmi
eux 500 enfants ne pourraient être
soignés
jean pierre le bonjour oui vous êtes
l'administrateur de la ligue contre le
cancer des yvelines aujourd'hui journée
internationale des cancers pédiatriques
pouvez vous nous rappeler les différents
cancers de l'enfant alors les différents
cancers de l'enfant on les suit divise
en deux les enfants de zéro jusqu'à 14
ans et ensuite il ya le cancer de
l'adolescent qui va de on va dire de 15
à 17 ans les différents cancers dont on
retrouve les leucémies qui sont les plus
les plus fréquentes avec 29% si vous
voulez des cancers dans ces cancers de
leucémies qu si vous voulez 80% sont des
lymphoblastique alors c'est peut-être un
terme un peu un peu barbare si vous
voulez les cellules souches fabrique de
deux catégories les lymphocytes et les
miels au site
les miels au site ce sont eux qui vont
fabriquer si vous voulez les et massy
pour le sang les globules rouges donc
autrement dit les plaquettes et les
monocytes par contre les lymphocytes
sont celles qui les placent donc sa
farce a fourni à chaque fois des blast
ce sont des thés cellules qu'ils ne sont
pas matures et qu'ils ne deviendront
jamais mature et qui l'avons dérégler le
système et ses lymphocytes fabrique
justement les locaux site pour le
défense immunitaire normalement
et là il ya un
ya un hiatus puisque ça ne se fait plus
le deuxième la deuxième cause des
cancers c'est les cancers du système
nerveux central
alors là c'est grosso modo si d'un côté
c'était les cellules osseuses
là on rentre dans la moelle épinière et
la moelle épinière et grosso modo c'est
on va dire aussi 25% des cas de cancer
est le troisième cas ce sont les
lymphome
il faut savoir que dans ce domaine là si
vous voulez à un an de survie on est
grosso modo à 90% et absym quand on
touche les 82 82 et demi pour cent de
rémission parce qu'en cancer on parle
toujours de rémission parle jamais de
guérison pour les adolescents c'est de
15 à 17 ans et là on a le retrouve le
même genre de cancer mais totalement
différent
c'est à dire que les premiers cancers
qui sont au diagnostic et ce sont des
cancers du lymphome ensuite on retrouve
le système nerveux central
et puis en troisième partie toujours
pareil les leucémies ou là il ya ce
fameux seulement 63% de lymphoblastique
on connaît encore très mal les causes
des cancers pédiatriques les facteurs
favorisent ont traditionnellement les
cancers chez l'adulte comme l'alcool la
cigarette mais on ne peut pas dire que
ça ne peut pas s'appliquer aux enfants
donc les cancers de l'enfant sont-ils
génétique ou dues à l'environnement à
lorsque l'on ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui si vous voulez puisque les
trois quarts des cancers si vous voulez
de l'enfant apparaissent avant 5 ans
donc autrement dit ça veut dire que ça
se passe au niveau du foetus ou il ya
certainement un d un dérèglement
chromosomique et on parle souvent des
cancers de l'adulte et moins des enfants
l'association imagine fort margot a
lancé pendant tout le mois de février
une campagne nationale de
sensibilisation à la cause du cancer des
enfants avec comme parrain le chanteur
mika vous pouvez voir ces photos pour
les enfants la maladie engendre des
contraintes notamment avec la
chimiothérapie
quelles sont les conséquences pour
l'enfant pour leur vie future
est ce qu'il y à des risques pour la
fertilité oui donc aujourd'hui la ligue
si vous voulez ils luttent justement
pour que la fertilité soit reconnue si
vous voulez haut niveau
de la fertilité pour les jeunes filles
comme pour les garçons
car après 15 ans 17 ans c'est là que les
problèmes vont rire se pose est donc bon
je dirais on congèle si vous voulez
souad et des spermatozoïdes soit des
ovocytes au niveau des des jeunes filles
et comme on l'a vu dans le reportage les
parents de jérôme ont appris le cancer
de leur enfant lorsqu'il avait 4 ans est
un véritable chamboulement dans la vie
des parents la ligue contre le cancer
fédère 103 comités départementaux sur
tout le territoire national comment avec
votre association accompagne et vous les
parents dans cette épreuve difficile
alors dans cette épreuve difficile les
parents bons peuvent toujours s'adresser
aux comités départementaux pour deux
pour être soutenue par d je dirai à la
limite des rendez vous et des
psychologues d'autres si vous voulez
d'autres possibilités c'est que la ligue
va pouvoir aider financièrement les
parents qui sont dans une grande
précarité
par exemple en payant des hébergements
en payant des trajets pour se rendre à
l'hôpital
et puis il ya des groupes de paroles où
les parents peuvent venir pour je dirais
dialoguer avec d'autres parents et au
travers de je dirais de avec un
psychologue si vous voulez et en enfants
malades du cancer ne se soigne pas comme
un adulte modèle réduit les cancers
pédiatriques ondes et des spécificités
dont la recherche doit tenir compte
quels sont les types de traitement pour
les cancers de l'enfant
alors pour les cancers de l'enfant bas
il ya les trois types de traitement je
dirais que l'on va retrouver je dirais
aussi chez les adultes c'est la
chirurgie c'est la radiothérapie et puis
la chimiothérapie avec tous les dégâts
que ça peut engendrer
alors justement une proposition de loi a
été déposée par nathalie et limal c'est
jean-noël barrot visons à renforcer la
prise en charge des cancers pédiatriques
par la recherche le soutien aux aidants
familiaux
la formation des professionnels et le
droit à l'oubli est actuellement à
lecture au sénat
cette loi alors je vous donne quelques
points fondamentaux c'est proposer
l'abaissement
l'âge minimal de 18 ans actuellement
requis pour les essais cliniques afin de
permettre une adéquation entre ces
derniers et l'âge du patient
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
quel âge faudrait-il fixée pour ces
essais cliniques
justement la ligue si vous voulez lutte
un petit peu vis-à-vis de ces essais
cliniques de phase on allait aller
vulgariser si vous voulez au travers d'
équipes de recherche parce que
aujourd'hui on constate si vous voulez
que les laboratoires sont un petit peu
frileuse si vous voulez pour proposer
des molécules innovantes pour justement
les jeunes enfants donc la ligue avec
les avec certains chercheurs et
notamment vis-à-vis de chu comme celui
de léon bérard à lyon
le ch u2 de marseille gustave roussy à
paris l'institut pour le cancer etc
il ya des essais cliniques qui sont
faits et actuellement il ya 270 enfants
qui en bénéficient il ya également dans
cette loi une goutte de l'oubli c'est à
dire de permettre à ses de permettre si
vous voulez à l'enfant lorsqu'il
deviendra majeur qu'il aura besoin
d'emprunter ou de contracter une
assurance que ce concert au bout de cinq
ans soit oubliée et lui permettent de ne
pas payer des surprimes si vous voulez
pour pour pour une assurance ou pour
emprunter et pour débloquer des fonds
pour la recherche des traitements
quelles sont les actions que vous mettez
en place avec la ligue contre le cancer
des yvelines alors avec la ligue contre
le cancer des yvelines si vous voulez
comme avec la ligue nationale si vous
voulez
nous avons toujours lutté pour que l'on
puisse reconnaître si vous voulez les
cancers pédiatriques et de là c'est
partager aujourd'hui avec les centres
leclerc qui vont pendant la période de
la deuxième quinzaine du mois de mars du
15 au 31 avec les comités départementaux
récolter ce sont des bénévoles de la
ligue contre le cancer et notamment de
la ligue contre le cancer des yvelines
qui vont être à l'entrée des caisses
proposer un petit flyer et chaque
personne pourra remettre si vous voulez
une somme de 2 euros sur son sur la
caisse et bien souvent les centres
leclerc abonde dans ce sens en cette
journée des cancers pédiatriques c'est
l'occasion pour appeler chacun à
soutenir la recherche
vous avez en bas de l'écran qui
s'affiche juste ici le site de la ligue
du contre le cancer ou si vous le
souhaitez les donateurs
vous pouvez faire un bon merci jean
pierre le haut puis d'avoir été avec
nous je le rappelle vous êtes
l'administrateur de la ligue contre le
cancer 2000 soit or voilà contre la
ligue du cancer des yvelines merci merci
et on passe au reste de l'actualité de
la semaine
[Musique]
sentez toujours lundi se déroulait la
journée internationale de l'épilepsie
cette maladie se traduit par une
activité électrique anormale du cerveau
et l'épilepsie a beau toucher et six
cent mille français elle est encore très
mal prise en charge
témoignage d'un mère et de son fils
l'épilepsie est un mal invisible
isabelle méline s'est aperçue que son
fils théo souffrait d'épilepsie à l'âge
de 7 ans et demi la cause une tumeur
cérébrale c'est alors le cri d'une maman
pour toutes les autres mamans
isabelle méline devient la
correspondante locale des yvelines de
l'association épilepsie france car
souvent les familles se retrouvent
isolés face à la maladie s'ajoutent
l'éloignement par manque de prise en
charge en ile-de-france des épileptiques
pour notre fils théo il a d'abord vécu à
la guitare ici à un million pendant
trois ans et après il n'y avait plus
rien pour lui donc on a dû le mettre
dans un centre spécialisé pour
l'épilepsie en bretagne et suite à la
bretagne
il s'est retrouvé sur toulouse et c'est
là qu'il a préparé un bac professionnel
en gestion administration
vous pensez que ça aurait pu aller mais
l'épilepsie vraiment difficile à vivre
et c'est pas possible qu'il puisse
continuer en vient de la langue bien
nous le dira il faisait que cette
victoire par semaine mais malgré ça cet
allégement il ya encore des crises qui
sont trop présentes qui peut pas suivre
et prendre trop de retard
on aurait aimé faire différent mais
c'est impossible de faire ça en tout cas
pour l'instant dans les yvelines
deuxième pathologies neurologiques en
france les médecins traitent l'épilepsie
mais pas les répercussions sur la vie
sociale des malades
avec les crises nortune ça m'empêche
énormément de bad être vraiment actifs
du coup je m'endors concours très vite
donc les utilisent les aigles les
activités ses scoops vêtements que
social le combat n'est pas terminé pour
la mère et son fils ils se battent pour
une meilleure prise en charge de cette
maladie au sein de la société notamment
dans les écoles elles les professeurs
sont déjà entier pour la rentrée
prochaine ils se sont rassemblés devant
la direction des services départementaux
de l'éducation nationale de guyancourt
ce mouvement organisé par la section
départementale snes fsu a rassemblé une
cinquantaine de personnes et plusieurs
établissements scolaires des yvelines il
conteste la dotation horaire attribuée
pour la rentrée qui engendre la
suppression de postes d'options mais
surtout des classes plus surchargées les
précisions avec ce reportage
stop mépris lycée en colère voici les
messages que proclament les
contestataires sur les banderoles
déployées devant le dsden la direction
des services départementaux de
l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui on est sur une mobilisation
dans le cadre de la préparation rentrée
2010 neuf donc les moyens pour faire
fonctionner les établissements à la
rentrée sont arrivés dans les
établissements et donc les personnes qui
sont rassemblés derrière moi et qui se
manifestent sont là pour réclamer
davantage de moyens pour préparer leur
rentrée professeurs et parents inquiet
de la dotation horaire globale
ce nombre d'heures d'enseignement
attribué par établissement qui sert à
réaliser la répartition des classes
cette année la dotation horaire globale
qui a été allouée a été diminué ce qui
fait que
classe va être supprimé je pense qu'on
n'a pas même enseignement canton et 26
élèves dans une classe où quand on est
31 32
l'enseignant ne peut pas avoir la même
attention avec tous les élèves mais bon
ça devient des enseignements plus
difficile
motivée non résigné les enseignants
déplorent la dégradation des conditions
d'enseignement et veulent le faire
entendre aux représentants de la déesse
des yens ce qui risque de disparaître en
tout cas dé diminuer ses les dispositifs
dettes qui sont proposées aux élèves en
terme de dédoublement par exemple pour
les matières expérimentales ou des
dédoublements avec des groupes de
besoins dans mathématiques en français
on pourra certainement proposer moins
que ce qu'on propose aujourd'hui
l'insuffisance des dotations se
manifeste également par des suppressions
de postes pour le département des
yvelines en estime que c'est environ une
trentaine de postes à peu près 13 13 en
collège et aux 18 ans lycée neuf
établissements demandé à être reçus par
la direction des services départementaux
de l'éducation nationale en fin d'après
midi les enseignants envisagent d'autres
actions avec le soutien des parents les
élèves inquiets eux aussi en pleine
réflexion sur leur avenir professionnel
des réponses qu'ils ont pu trouver à
l'occasion de la nuit des métiers de
l'orientation la dernière édition vient
de se tenir à montigny le bretonneux
un jeune sur deux douteraient de ses
compétences pour réussir son parcours si
l'on en croit le dernier sondage
opinionway dévoilé la semaine dernière
un sondage qui révèle aussi que les
parents ne sont pas toujours d'un grand
secours pour faire les bons choix
d'orientation ya 30 40 ans nos parents
et grands parents
choisissez un métier épousé sa
généralement quasiment toute leur vie
on sait aujourd'hui que une grande
partie de ces jeunes exerceront hamiti
qui est totalement inconnu ce jour qu'on
parle de plus de 50% de meetic qui vont
se créer ça veut dire que d'autres vont
mourir donc ça veut dire que certains se
questionnent sur comment bien se
préparer à l'évolution du monde dans
lequel on évolue aujourd'hui
cette année la nuit des métiers de
montigny le bretonneux a donc ouvert ses
portes aux étudiants pour évoquer leur
parcours à leurs cadets et cette mère a
échangé avec une étudiante en médecine
on a échangé la première année de
médecine donc leur ressenti savoir au
niveau de l'intensité des cours
ben ce que ça représentait donc
voilà qui est hésitant aujourd'hui ça
lui permettra de d'avoir déjà davantage
d'informations sur le sujet mais c'est
bien la réforme du bac et la disparition
des filières traditionnelles qui suscite
le plus d'inquiétude si l'on en croit
les parents présents à des changements
encore faim les kazakhs les options mais
disons qu'on a les tenants n'en a pas
forcément les aboutissants les chemins
pour y aller donc ça c'est encore
l'investigation complète dès l'an
prochain les lycéens choisiront des
spécialités afin de mieux appréhender
l'enseignement supérieur d'où
l'importance de faire les meilleurs
choix
enfin le pôle jeunesse a aussi présenté
des solutions alternatives aux jeunes en
rupture de scolarité du service civique
à la mobilité européenne elle si vous
avez manqué ce rendez vous il est
possible de venir se renseigner tout au
long de l'année et les lycées en
profiteront peut-être de ce week-end
pour formuler leurs voeux sur parcours
su c'est jusqu'au 13 mars 18h pour
saisir les voeux nous passons à présent
à notre rubrique ça s'est passé comme
chaque vendredi retour sur l'actualité à
travers nos archives et le 13 février se
tenait la journée mondiale de la radio
l'occasion de revenir sur la création de
la dernière radio libre des yvelines
marmite fm attrape en 2002
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur mon lit
tiphaine 95 j'espère que vous passez une
bonne journée
[Musique]
dernière née des radios associatives la
maison de l'action radiophonique et de
la mobilité des idées sur trappe et ses
environs on prenait la marmite s'est
installé cet été sur le 88.4 une
nouvelle radio associative qui place la
barre très haut en proposant des
programmes citoyens éducatifs culturels
mais aussi expérimentaux à l'image des
digues de la station pour le moins
inédit sur la bande fm vous avez écouté
ma vous écouterez à l'antenne ce sont
les bénévoles qui s'exprime et plus
particulièrement les habitants de
trappes toutes les émissions sont
réalisées par des amateurs
mais pas question pour ces responsables
d'en faire une radio de seconde zone
je voulais une antenne professionnelle
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on est
associative qu'on peut se permettre de
faire tout et n'importe quoi et c'est
vrai que moi j'avais envie d'une antenne
professionnel c'est pour ça qu'on se
donne le droit de refaire et de refaire
des émissions de faire un pilote de
refaire une émission juste jusqu'à tant
qu'elles soient professionnelles à mon
goût des émissions qui recherchent une
qualité professionnelle ouverte sur la
musique les communautés ou encore les
écoles qui viennent compléter et gris
musical tout aussi diversifiée on essaye
de toucher un maximum de la population
autre a donc on aimait mais carrément
tous les genres de musique
on a eu des retours il ya des personnes
qui disent que
même bien justement parce que il ya un
mélange de plein de genres de musique et
des gens qui n'écoutent pas forcément de
la chanson française
il écoute quelques morceaux disent ah
tiens fui la libye
donc qui commence à apprécier donc on
essaye de bien faire ça plus que
trouvait jean trappe
après si bien cette radio l'antenne de
marmites fm n'a pas fini de se
développer une émission sur les droits
des citoyens est en cours de préparation
mais pour recevoir chaque jour de
nouvelles propositions il faut avant
tout faire connaître la radio entre en
contact c'est presque individuellement
aller leur parler leur faire comprendre
que la radio c'est pour tout le monde
si pour vous la faire aux enfers parce
que
parce que c'est pas évident il pense que
c'est pas à leur portée ils leur
expliquer il faut simplement parler de
ce dont on a envie de parler leur
quotidien de choses qui les passionne
que vous soyez trappistes ou non et si
vous avez des projets d'émissions
contacter directement la radio pour les
grands timides qui préfèrent rester
derrière leur poste marmite fm et mais
sur un rayon de près de 30 km les lundi
mardi jeudi et vendredi de 13h à 18h et
le mercredi de 13h à 21h le week end les
ondes sont en ébullition à partir de 9h
jusqu'à 13 heures allez bonne journée
écouter marc métais même 90 points 4
[Musique]
avant de clôturer le journal le reste de
l'actualité en ile-de-france avec nos
confrères de via grand paris
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous partons à montmagny
dans le val d'oise plus précisément à la
ferme où des personnes sont condamnées à
du travail d'intérêt général
des tiges parmi eux samir une
remobilisation par le travail les pieds
dans la terre et au contact des animaux
ses chèvres sont nourris par des
personnes effectuant des peines de
travaux d'intérêt général
c'est juste comme on les appelle
prennent part à la vie de cette ferme
pédagogique situé à montmagny une
alternative à la prison que souhaite
développer nicole belloubet garde des
sceaux dans le cadre de sa réforme de la
justice
actuellement nous avons à peu près 18
mille postes de travaux d'intérêt
général qui sont disponibles et nous
souhaiterions monte à 30 mille postes en
quelques années en deux ou trois ans
parce que il nous semble qu'il y à là
véritablement d atout puissant pour que
les personnes qui sont condamnées à des
tiges puisse trouver les voies d'une
réadaptation et d'une réinsertion
sociale cette ferme est géré par une
association
les fermiers de la francilienne
principal partenaire de la justice pour
le travail d'intérêt général
en ile de france depuis son ouverture en
ils sont plus de 500 issus du val d'oise
et de seine saint denis à être passés
par ici
samir est l'un d'eux à 44 ans ce chef
d'entreprise a été arrêté à plusieurs
reprises au volant d'un véhicule sans
avoir de permis de conduire il a dû
choisir entre purgé une peine de prison
ou effectuer un travail d'intérêt
général me mettre dans un cadre et dans
un milieu qui n'est pas forcément le
lien et qui va pas du tout qui va rien
m'apporter non ce n'est peut-être me
faire basculer d'un côté du côté obscur
je n'ai pas forcément envie de créer des
contacts de nouer des liens avec des
gens qui sont du banditisme qui sont des
voyous notoires
je vois pas comment ça peut faire
évoluer ma vie est plus m'a mené vers
des penchants que pour me remettre dans
le droit chemin
à l'avenir ce type de peine pourrait
être élargi au secteur privé et aux
entreprises de service public
la garde des sceaux annonce également la
création d'une agence nationale du
travail d'intérêt général pour décembre
prochain elle devra promouvoir ses
peines et recenser les offres
disponibles
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information dans le 7-8 journal
lundi à 18h passer un excellent week-end
[Musique]